[Music]
3
venom 2 setup for spider-verse let's
watch this
from cw the network
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and as
we get closer and
closer to the end of the year hoping for
that spider-man
marvel and sony are pretty much going
all out with this film
if even half of the cast that is rumored
to be a part of this film
ends up showing up in the movie it will
be completely insane
and today we get to throw in two more
names for the rumor mail for spider-man
three cameos
where's this tom hardy as venom and
jared litto as morbius now since
spider-man 3 is supposed to introduce
the spider-verse
these choices make perfect sense
especially venom and venom will be a
great addition because if we are doing a
live-action spider-verse
venom wasn't in the animated into the
spider-verse film
in into the spider-verse we got a little
taste of what a spider-verse would be
like
and now we're getting a live action one
and it's super exciting but we don't
want it to be exactly the same as into
the spider verse so
having venom appear in spider-man 3
would be a very
very good touch but today is the first
time that it's been rumored that venom
and possibly morbidity
make more sense for morbius because of
that poster take a look back we actually
kind of have proof to this already
the morbius trailer actually connected
morbius and the spumc the sony because
of that poster too
and also yeah
and don't forget about that picture on
the wall of spider-man oh thank god he
mentioned it
he mentioned the thing oh thank god that
we maybe didn't know one shot that
overshadowed the entire trailer
toby mcguire spider-man now we caught
that damn trying to be interesting
we realized it was a sam raimi suit but
we thought that maybe it was just
because of some
rights issues or some unknown reason but
we are a mistake
this is a joke but now that we know that
spider-man 3 is going to be a
spider-verse film
perhaps this is tobey maguire's sam
raimi spider-man existing in this other
universe that morbius is in
and perhaps the spider-verse is going to
be how the universes connect instead of
just acting like they exist in the same
universe there was a rumor going around
not too long ago when the spider-man
disney sony deal was finally settled and
the rumors were
that sony could put sony characters such
as
venom and morbius in spider-man films in
the mcu and
however they could only go into the mcu
if they were only in spider-man films
meaning venom or
any other character couldn't show up in
any other film that wasn't a spider-man
film
this makes it entirely possible for
morbius and
venom to appear in spider-man 3. and if
we're going to have
a bunch of villains cameoing and taking
on spider-man
in the third film why not have venom and
also keep in mind this could be set up
before
we actually get to spider-man 3 which is
a year from now
[Music]
i don't know i don't really know
i'm kind of confused do i want either
one
we have adrian tombs as vulture actually
talking to morbius in one of the scenes
they showed spider-man on the wall and
they have shown that david's
photos from the set that we have seen
this is so confusing because
this would make a lot of sense but i
don't know if i want it yet
spider-man 3. and then we have venom 2
let there be carnage
set to come out just a couple of months
not even
before spider-man 3. and since morbius
exists in the same universe that venom
does and morbius is tying into these
somehow i mean if that if it's
good and it works that could be really
cool actually be surprised if we see a
tom holland or spider-man champion
a quick one perhaps at some point in
time let there be carnage or in the past
i don't know watching the news the daily
bugle
j jonah jameson pops up on the screen
and they see the report about
spider-man and peter parker and that
would set up a very smooth way for venom
to appear in spider-man 3 and then
hopefully go head-to-head against
spider-man in another film
unfortunately right now spider-man 3 is
going to have so many characters we
probably won't get a venom or spider-man
battle but simply a venom cameo
so let's hope this rumor is true because
i know a lot of us would really love to
see venom and spider-man finally
interact and
inside of the mcu so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos as soon as i hear
more i'll be sure to update everybody
don't forget to like the video and let
me know how excited you are for
spider-man 3 in the past
i'm very excited it's just that
you want spider-man 3 first so much for
watching
woof woof we'll keep this quick the
rumor goes that tom holland
might appear in venom 2 probably to help
out carnage or maybe a post-credits
scene something like that and to me that
seems appropriate it makes
more sense out of anyone to appear in
this crazy spider-verse movie
to have like all these multiple villains
it does make more sense to have venom
and morbius
in here because of the fact that they're
already existing franchises that are
currently running yes you can call more
beats a franchise already it's meant to
be a franchise so you know it's already
gonna be coming out in theaters right so
it makes sense of the one-two punch
of morbius venom then you put them in
spider-verse
but here's the thing where i'm
conflicted is that if you are
setting these guys up to one day
crossover with spider-man
i kind of feel like it should be in
something that will not be
this these are all villains and
characters that they're bringing back
who have already been established
through like previous spider-man films
and it's a different type of nostalgic
crossover fun
versus building characters up to one day
go toe-to-toe with spider-man
it's a very different type of setup i
would want that to be a little bit more
of an
isolated movie versus them
being in this one where i feel like
people will just be way more excited
about you know toby mcguire
andrew garfield and the other returning
characters yeah
all the people we've been talking about
all this time yeah and i kind of think
that this should be something where it's
its own thing
that being said i mean yeah who i of
course want to see
venom spiderman get towed i want to see
tom hardy and tom hollands
go toe to toe that's the one i'm i'm
like really gnawing at so i mean if we
get it we get it
uh but i prefer something where it's a
little cameo in venom 2
versus them being here although that
would open up the doors for all kinds of
crazy mayhem and
the fact that vulture is in morbius and
you do see spider-man in the background
there and that is a
sony film it does start changing the
game in terms of
how sony is probably cooperating and
working their stories along the lines of
the mcu
because remember when amy pascal and
that funny interview came out yeah where
he's like yeah venom has nothing to do
with it we're not venom at all
and it seems like that's really changed
now especially because morbius has those
characters in there
yeah so i don't know
yeah i mean this is conflicted i'm
excited but also not really
sure i wanted it for this one likewise
i'm pretty much on your wavelength
because what i'm worried about now is
just
is sony learning the right lessons from
some of the things they're obviously
trying to make up for
in the past with this yeah i don't want
either morbius or venom 2 to become
vehicles for spider-man
i want them to you know establish those
characters and if they have a spider-man
feature like this got me thinking
because you know in the morbius trailer
it's specifically the tobey maguire
version so now i'm thinking
are they going to introduce the concept
of toby's
toby spider-man coming back in that
movie and then do something with andrew
garfield in venom or
or you know maybe do a little tom
holland appearance or something it's
it's making me curious as to how
intentional these choices are
other than just to go hey we're gonna
bring them in eventually so like it is
exciting on the one hand but i guess i'm
still
wary of like okay these two movies are
like very much
on the sony side of the sony marvel venn
diagram
yeah and so those are the ones where i'm
a little more wary of like okay
yeah don't get overshadowed by throwing
a bunch of spider-man at this and not
actually
looking at what the movie itself
deserves or whatever and yeah i wouldn't
want it to be more than little tastes
really personally i doubt venom will
show up in this movie i i really
yeah i doubt venom will show up i feel
like morbius is more of a likely
candidate
just because of what we saw in that in
the trailer already i doubt it though
i really do you would really want to see
tom holland and tom hardy like
make an event of it go toe-to-toe and
really have them square off each other
and have eddie and peter square off each
other like yeah it would be too much to
have him be in there as a side thought
you know
but i don't know i think i'm likely to
change my opinion depending on how
awesome if they just do a good job with
whatever they do i mean it'll be fun
all right guys well do you want venom to
appear in this spider-man 3 movie do you
think it'd be too much
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification
bell thanks warren for putting this
video together hope you had a good
holidays my my faith my faith believer
friend
celebrating the actual birth of christ
you sexy jesus man you
heaven yeah see you guys